تعرف وجهات السفر المميزه والمناطق
المشهوره عالميا بساحه الاثرياء
جنايه تسوقون
الى العالم مثل جزر المالديف او شواطئ
اوروبا الساحله لكن ارتفاع التكلفه يحول
دون تحقيق ذلك فقد تصل اسعار المنتجعات
ثلاث او اربع نجوم في المالديف مثلا الى
اسعار منتجات اكثر من خمس نجوم في اماكن
اخرى
وهي وجهات سياحيه خفيه على فكره وتوفر
تجربه مشابهه بانشطه مميزه وبتكلفه اقل
بكثير الان راح نذهب للتلاميس ولديها
امثله على هذه الوجهات صدى وين نروح وين
ما بدك انت بتروح انت غني بتقدر
ثري سريع عربي
اذا المشاهدين مع اقتراب موسم ذروه
الاجازات نتعرف على وجهات صيف غير متوقعه
او ربما متوقعه يمكنك اخذها بعين الاعتبار
للسفر في 2023 وذلك بحسب سي ان
انجلترا في يونيو ستحتفل المدينه بمرور 25
عاما على مهرجان الفنون البصريه المعاصره
حيث يتولى اكثر من 30 فنان المساحاتا في
المدينه حتى سبتمبر رواندا شهدت هذا العام
الافتتاح الرسمي للفندق الاكثر اثاره وهو
عباره عن مجموعه من الاكواخ المصنوعه بشكل
تقليدي على جزيره عند بحيره كيفو اكبر
البحيرات في افريقيا
جوتنبرغ في السويد اختيرت كالوجه الاكثر
استدامه في العالم لمده 6 اعوام على
التوالي وهي الان واحده من اكثر وجهات
خضره في اوروبا وخمسه وتسعون بالمئه من
فنادقها صديقه للبيئه القاهره في مصر رغم
ان اهرامات الفيزا هي المعلم الجاذب
للمدينه لانه
لا يتناك المزيد لرؤيته خاصه مع توقعات
افتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير هذا العام
[موسيقى]
لحتى نعرف تفاصيل اكثر مشاهدينا معنا الان
المدير العام للشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
في شركه ويجو للطيران مامون حميدان اهلا
بك صباح الخير طيب صباح النور اذا وجهات
خفيه لانه الواحد جابو عم بيصغر او بنقدر
نقول بنقدر نقول عنده فقر دم او مخزوق
يعني مش عم بيجمع فلوس والاسعار عمالها
بتطلع كتير مثلا يعني في وجهات كلاسيكيه
لما نحكي فينيسيا ميكونوس
هدول كيف بدنا نلاقي اماكن بهذا الجمال
ولكن
بتكاليف اقل في اماكن كثير
ودائما في حديث عن موضوع وجهات التانيه او
المختلفه
مثلا عنا هون قبل ما نروح على على اوروبا
احنا اليوم عنا مثلا منطقه قريبه علينا
اللي هي اللي هي مسندم في عمان شبه جزيره
رائعه بتتمتع بطبيعه خلابه بمياه صافيه
بفرص استكشافيه مياه دافئها في فرص ممارسه
الغوص يمارسوا الغوص حتى لو سنورك حتى وصل
البدائي الناس الكل الناس قادره تقضي فيها
يومين ثلاثه بسهوله وبتكلفه كثير مختلفه
عن انا رحلات البعيده في منطقه في مصر
مثلا
اسمها شالي
هاي مدينه اول مره اسمع
الغردقه ممكن ذهب
المناطق
مش بالضروره غاليه كان معروفه
من من يعني فيها بيوت مبنيه من الطين
والملح قديمه تاريخيه فيها بناء بربري
قديم
في في مناطق في طبعا العلا اليوم في
السعوديه طبعا يعني منطقه مكتشفه لكن فيها
الكثير
استكشاف اللي بتقدمه للمسافرين في ابو ظبي
هون في عنا جزيره مثلا جزر الشهيره
الجزيره طبيعيه محميه كامله طبيعيه ممكن
يعيش فيها واحد اجواء قريبه جدا للسفاري
ممكن يعيشوا باي بلد افريقيا قبل شوي ربما
سالت
الروح راوندا او الروح اماكن جديده قد
تكون جميله ولكن قد يعني تكون غير امنه او
نخاف من هذا الموضوع لانه دائما الحديث
يكون او ما فيها خدمات يعني هذا اشواق على
فكره بتحب السفر كتير زميلتنا وبتسافر
كتير خصوصا على اسيا وهذا اشي كتير مهم
بالنسبه عندها فلوس كثير عندها فلوس
بشكل مشهورين
في في مناطق طبعا محتاج واحد يبحث بيحتاج
يتاكد
شو اللي
رواندا
روندا منطقه في الاندلس تمام عباره عن تل
باطلاله رائعه قريب على كل المناطق
المشروع بتتخيلها في الجنوب الاسباني لكن
لكن فيه يعني فيه محتوى وعرض مختلف تماما
بدنا نلعب انا راح اعطيك وجهه شهيره وانت
تعطيني بكلمه البديل ميكونوس في اليونان
جزيره ميكونوس
بعتقد
مناطق اللي في افريقيا الذي تونس او او في
تونس في اكثر مكان روما ناس تحب تروح روما
وين المكان بديل على الروما شوف قريب
لروما في منطقه مثلا في جنوب النمسا غير
مستكشفه بتقدم طبيعه ساحره وخدمات وعده
مدن جنب بعضها اسمها اوسيخ على سبيل
المثال بحيرات وحدائق ومدن وجمع في مدينه
كبيره اسمها كلاجون فورت اللي هي في
الجنوب النمساوي وقريبه جدا
وترجع مره ثانيه فهي من بالي في اندونيسيا
في تايلاند ارخص ارخص ارخص بطوله ارخص
مكتشفه طبعا معروفه بس دائما بالي بوكيت
ولا بتايلند فيها اماكن غير مكتشفه تروح
الى الاماكن بانكوك الاماكن اللي صحيح بس
فيها اماكن
في في لنكاوي مثلا في ملجم كمان كمان
مناطق من الجزر الرائعه
الناس تحب الصيف اه هي لندن لندن وين نروح
بس لها ذائقه مختلفه
فيها بس انه لازم نغير هلا ضمن ضمن ضمن
اليوكيا ضمن المملكه المتحده فيه كتير
تمام في مدينه اسمها باس تقريبا ساعه ونص
من لندن طيب موضوع مختلف كليه ولا ولا في
بريطانيا غير عمار غير طريقه غير هذا مياه
شلالات
طبعا اسكتلندا طبعا
في بجانب ما بين ايدين
في في منطقه رائعه اسمها منطقه
يعني الكامل
جدا طيب احنا شاكرين لك لكن انا راح اقول
لك في يوم من الايام راح نروح الى عمان في
بر الحكمان برا رائع جدا هذا وما بعد بحر
كيف لا تسالني ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
شكرا جزيلا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات